.
WE HAVE AN UPDATE THIS MORNING
ON A STORY THAT JERICKA DUNCAN
HAS BEEN FOLLOWED FOR MORE THAN
A DECADE.
CARIOL HORNE WAS DISPLACED FROM
THE BUFFALO, NEW YORK, POLICE
DEPARTMENT AFTER SHE INTERVENED
WHEN A WHITE OFFICER USED A
CHOKE HOLD ON A BLACK MAN.
THIS WAS BACK IN 2006.
NOW A JUDGE HAS DECIDED TO
REVERSE THE TERMINATION AND
REINSTATE HER PENSION.
JERICKA DUNCAN SPOKE TO HORNE
ABOUT WHY SHE KEPT FIGHTING ALL
THESE YEARS.
>> Reporter: CARIOL HORNE NEVER
STOPPED BELIEVING IN THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM.
DID YOU EVER THINK THIS DAY
WOULD COME?
>> I DID THINK THIS DAY WOULD
COME.
THAT'S WHY I KEPT FIGHTING.
>> Reporter: HORNE'S STORY GOES
BACK ALMOST 15 YEARS.
IN 2006 THE FORMER BUFFALO, NEW
BREATH SLIPCHAUVIN.
[ INAUDIBLE ] AROUND
[ INAUDIBLE ]
FOR USING UNLAWFUL AND
UNREASONABLE FORCE AGAINST FOUR
BLACK TEENAGERS.
IN OCTOBER OF LAST YEAR, BUFFALO
CITY'S MAYOR SIGNED THE DUTY TO
INTERVENE LAW WHICH WOULD
REQUIRE POLICE TO STEP IN IF A
FELLOW OFFICER USES EXCESSIVE
FORCE.
IT'S LEGISLATION HORNE HELPED
WRITE AND HAD BEEN PUSHING SINCE
2016.
>> WE DON'T WANT OTHER OFFICERS
TO GO THROUGH WHAT I'VE GONE
THROUGH.
WE DON'T WANT OTHER VICTIMS TO
GO THROUGH WHAT GEORGE FLOYD
WENT THROUGH.
>> Reporter: THAT SAME MONTH
WITH